What a time to be so young,...
...missing out on things we should have done.
All those new chapters, the first day of school,...
...making new friends, spending time with them all.
The stories we tell when we grew up and look back,...
...haven't even been written; those pages are blank.
And now Christmas is coming; the goose is getting fat.
The year we just had, we can all say that.
So let's make this Christmas one to really remember.
Do everything bigger, the best ever December.
Find secret places to wrap every box.
Dress up the tree; fill up your socks.
Do nothing by halves, all things considered.
Let Debenhams help and have Christmas delivered.
Make magical memories for the ones that we missed...
...because being together is what's top of the list.
So that years from now, our kids will still say,...
..."Christmas this year was my best ever day."